Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Las drogas de diseño,
la inteligencia artificial y el desarrollo,
en particular y en general,
van a cambiar el mapa de las enfermedades
durante los próximos años
tal como lo conocemos ahora.
Muchas de las enfermedades
que a Uds. les preocupan
en la próxima década van a comenzar
a atenuarse o a desaparecer.
Sin embargo, el progreso va a venir
con cambios en el medioambiente
en el que habitamos.
Antibióticos sofisticados
esterilizan nuestros intestinos
de muchas de las bacterias.
Detergentes de última generación
limpian nuestras casas,
las dejan libres de polvo.
El alcohol en gel le quita
las bacterias de las manos a los chicos
cuando vuelven de las plazas.
Las plazas que llenamos de baldosas
a las que llegamos
por calles que eran de tierra
y que ahora hemos pavimentado.
La tierra es tan importante
para nosotros como el oxígeno.
Nosotros masticamos tierra, comemos tierra,
respiramos tierra y tocamos tierra
desde el mismo día que
empezamos a respirar oxígeno.
El hombre va a asfixiarse en las próximas
décadas por falta de tierra.
Porque hay moléculas en la tierra
que son importantes
para desarrollar nuestro sistema inmune,
para sofisticar nuestros intestinos,
para crecer nuestros pulmones,
para prevenir las alergias,
para mejorar el asma.
El hombre en su burbuja
va a empezar a ver enfermedades
que hoy son poco comunes
o quizás inexistentes
por haberse divorciado de la tierra.
Así que la medicina, una vez que comience
y termine de festejar
haber despejado de nuestras vidas
estas enfermedades que tanto tememos,
se va a tener que poner a buscar tierra.
Pero lo va a tener que hacer
de forma inteligente, con la ciencia,
cuando seamos todos, quienes
vivimos hoy y en el futuro,
más ricos y viviendo mejor,
para buscar tierra, mugre segura.
Roña para ricos.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)